hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about how to relieve
SI joint pain what does si stand for
sacroiliac joint okay so now you have
the pelvis right here right and then we
have two little joints right there so if
we look at the back part we got this
thing called the sacrum which is the
foundation of your pelvis and then we
have these two little bones right here
that are called ilion's
okay so we have sacroiliac joints so
they move right back here you got two of
them and that's where they're located
okay so what I want to talk about I want
to talk about there's three different
causes of sacroiliac joint pain the most
common one which I'm going to give you a
demo is referred pain so the pain in
this little joint could be referred from
if it's in a female body the ovary the
ovary if there's a cyst there if there's
a problem there it will refer pain
exactly right behind to the back part
okay and if that's the case I'm going to
show you a really simple little test to
see if that is the problem and if it
turns off the pain then we know there
could be a problem there and you just
need to add a little seek help seek help
has iodine iodine reduces estrogen it
helps with cysts on the ovaries and that
usually resolves it pretty nicely
okay so so if it's referred pain it's
not coming from the you know you never
hurt your back the whole thing and
especially if it happens that time of
the month we know it's going to be the
ovary I've had a lady come in the office
and her ovary it was blowing out the SI
joint that is causing the joint to
misalign so I sent her to the doctor for
an ultrasound the ovary was the size of
a lemon it should be the size of an
almond okay it's swole up and that
pushed pressure all the way back there
and throughout her her back
on that side so we gave her some seek
help and the thing started shrinking
more and more and more over time and all
the pain went away now in a male body
they don't have ovaries okay so but they
do have these
little tubes that come down from the
kidney and they're called the ureters
they're just basically tubes from the
kidney to the bladder and a lot of times
they might have a little bit of a stone
or a little calcium deposit or a uric
acid crystal right into that little tube
where it connects to the bladder so if
that's the case I'm gonna show you how
to test for that ovary is located right
here okay so you have the hip right here
it's lower so what you want to do since
let's say that pretend the pain is on
her right SI joint she's gonna press
into the over in the same side so just
take your your fingers and just kind of
press and massage gently into that over
it okay just gonna do that for maybe 15
seconds now what's gonna happen either
the pain in her back is gonna go away or
it's not okay okay relax if the pain
goes away then we know there's a
connection between this and her back and
if that's the case we're gonna recommend
seek help okay I have my own version
with the from Iceland it's organic
because it's real pure or you can just
find another one that's equivalent but
the estrogen needs to come down to help
any cysts or anything going on in your
bruise so if it was on this ovary you
would do the opposite side on that on
this side here so you do this side right
here okay so that's how you would do it
if it's referred now in a male body
let's pretend that you're a guy what's
gonna happen you would press the same
spot and what that is the kidneys right
here and it connects with the tube down
into the bladder there's going to be a
little point right there were a lot of
times a uric acid crystal or a stone
might just sit right there and irritate
and refer back to the SI joint so again
you press right there if the pain goes
away then we know there could be some
junk there that you need to take some
potassium citrate that's what you need
to get and you can get it as a
supplement anywhere it's really simple
it's really inexpensive you take it and
that will be great for dissolving any
stones that you might have because one
of the things that if you're on the
ketogenic diet you may start
more susceptible to kidney stones but
potassium citrate is the antidote and
it's really good to take especially
since potassium you lose your potassium
when you go on a ketogenic diet so
especially if you don't eat enough
vegetables so that's what we want to
retain there now if you have the actual
joint pain then I'm gonna show you how
to deal with that you're basically gonna
press you're gonna need someone's help
but you can actually do it if you have a
tennis ball let's say you hurt let's say
the problem is not being referred it's
actually coming from the joint because
you sit because you know the sideways or
something like that
and you just have some inflammation
there or an injury whatever then what
you do is if you hurt on the right side
you lay on your back on a tennis ball on
the opposite side so if she hurts on the
right you could have someone massage on
the left and work that out and work out
the muscles that are connected to the SI
joint and that would be the glutes and
these muscles up here or you she could
be laying on her back with a tennis ball
right here and putting pressure on the
opposite side okay so if the pains over
here you press on the opposite side if
the pain is over here you press on this
side and that's the way you get rid of
pain in the SI joint and the last
technique is if you fell on your
tailbone a long time ago and you smack
your tailbone and the force travels up
to the spine up in the back of the neck
what happens the whole spine becomes
very rigid from that point on and
because there's a little it's kind of
like saran wrap it's called the dura
that's in an info spinal column that
thing gets tight and it can pull and
keep one of the sacroiliac joints tight
or even the lower back so it could come
from that if that's the case I'm going
to show you how to correct that there's
a certain stretch on that so so let's go
ahead and do the demo right now so check
this next part out now if someone fell
on their tailbone the force hits the
tailbone goes right up to the back of
the skull right here and so what you
want to do and you're going to need
someone to do this on you
but to get rid of a tailbone injury we
actually work on the neck part okay so
what you want to do is you want to take
the back of the neck and I have my
finger attached here and we're going to
stretch I'm lifting up on the back part
and I'm pushing down on my hand kind of
like taking a basketball and rotating it
so we want to take the finger gently
underneath the skull lift up stretch up
and then flex it down okay making sure
that we're not pulling her hair and then
we're gonna stretch this about I do like
seven times okay and then I'll also do
the other side
with my thumb it'll come and I'll lift
it up this way and I'm just lifting the
skull up and stretching forward and try
not to mess up her hair which is the
most important thing okay and what
you're going to do is you're going to
create the space that's going to release
the tension all the way down to the SI
joints and the back will feel like it's
tingly and warm and like the circulation
it's a great way to handle an old injury
from the tailbone so go ahead and apply
this put your comments below